so let's do a little public math here
let's break a rule he just launched this
product he had more demand than he was
willing to let in he let in 5,000 people
that's 20 million in ARR that he had on
day one of launching this
[Music]
product all right what's up it's me and
Sam two guys who you can't live
without you know I should really think
about what I'm gonna say before I start
this I literally just start talking and
whatever comes out of my mouth is fine
and then also it's 9:00 am for me I you
know I wake up I don't talk to anyone
from 8 AM to 9: am so these are the
first words I say period and that's what
came out all right well here we are we
both have one Topic in both of our lists
which is very very rare that we have
overlap here we both have this topic
because there's a business that's sold
for $500 million that is a badass story
and it's called follow-up boss I had
never heard of this company before I
find out they sell for 500 million in
cash tell me about followup B you I
think you know more you know how I know
about them I know about them for two
reasons the biggest reason they're
Hampton member and so I saw them post
that they had just uh sold man this
story is crazy so I had never heard of
this company have you never heard of
them till today so there's not really a
reason why we would have heard of them
other than for we're just business nerds
but it's a real estate platform so it's
a it's a vertical software and so
basically the gist of it is that if you
are a real estate agent or if you own a
company that has multiple real estate
agents you get leads from redin Zillow
whatever else ideally you get thousands
of leads per month as well as you have
homes that you're selling and people who
are buying homes you have to track them
all it's basically kind of what HubSpot
or Salesforce does but specifically for
real estate agents the guy Dan he
started it 12 years ago I think do you
know how he started it that's what's
fascinating about it I don't know how he
started it but but you're right so the
the gist of it is it's a niched down CRM
so agents get leads they need to follow
up with those leads you got to keep
track of all those leads so it's a sort
of HubSpot for real estate agents just
zoomed in zoomed way in on that one
Niche um has a pretty insane exit so how
did they start it so they what was the
final sale $500 million the $400 million
uh up front in cash and then another 100
million earnout listen how this guy
started his name's Dan he's from
Australia but they live in Wyoming now
so I guess it's it's technically it's a
remote company but they're a Wyoming
startup it's got to be one of the bigger
Tech exits out of Wyoming man listen to
this so he actually went through the
foundation do you remember that course
like 10 years ago it was like a course
to teach you how to start a startup the
foundation no I've never heard of that
yeah that's what it was called and uh it
so it's like their greatest success
story I guess now but they he went to
this thing and he started just trolling
Facebook groups and he was like working
a normal job he was a marketer at uh a
normal big company and he was like I
want to start a company I need some
ideas and so he was like well I I've got
a buddy in real estate that kind of
interests me so I'm so he started
joining these Facebook groups for real
estate agents and he just started like
skimming in all the posts of like what
are people complaining about what's like
a common thing and he saw this guy
complain he's like man I'm paying 500
bucks a month for the software that I
hate for tracking all my leads it kind
of stinks like how are you guys like
tracking your leads and he saw like okay
that's interesting and so he partnered
with a guy who's a developer a friend of
his who's a developer they build an MVP
they say that it took them like six six
months and they only had one customer
paying 150 bucks a month but he said he
goes man we built like this interview
that I read with him is a few years old
so I don't know if it was true till the
end but he's like we basically built our
entire business on Facebook but not
Facebook ads he goes I would just go
into all these Facebook groups as the
CEO and I would see them talk about like
uh hey what's a good platform for this
and it wasn't even related to followup
web boss which was his software company
he was like I was just like being
helpful constantly and people would
click my Facebook profile and see that I
was the CEO of this one platform or this
one tech company and then they would
click off and buy it and I would call
them and become friends with them but he
became they found this idea just to
trolling Facebook groups and they would
see people complain about stuff and he
would DM them on Facebook and be like
hey I think I'm building a solution for
you uh I don't care if you buy it or not
but like could you just give me 10
minutes of your time so I can figure out
make sure I'm solving the right problem
and he did this so often that that's
they came up with this idea for this
software they bootstrapped the whole
company I don't know how much the
revenue was the the the only source that
I found was uh a source that I don't
entirely Trust online but it was like 28
million a year in Revenue less than a
employees and a huge exit don't people
have to tell you the revenue when you
join Hampton don't you just have this
can't you just take a peek at the quick
Hipp a record here but I would never
cite that and so I'm so I just Googled
like uh you know follow-up boss revenue
and I'm just like what what can I see
that's public so
so I don't know yeah this this is a um
an awesome story and a good example of
kind of the niche down uh the niche down
zoom in pivot and I think that this is a
you know there's many like um business
plan blueprints so for example those
guys from 37 signals that what they're
doing is they just go hey what's a super
popular thing but has too many features
we're going to make it do less it take
up less of your life and that's like an
as an example you know hey they email
client they're like yeah just it's just
going to do these things in this way
less features the better less clutter
the better and they're doing it again
with Once where they're doing software
that you only have to pay for one time
no monthly recurring right so that their
thing is it's the strip down version of
X I don't know if you saw I don't know
if you saw but the guys who started uh
tough to needle came out with a new
company did you see this crazy what's it
called boring mattress boring mattress
so the guys who created T needle they
were part of the D Toc you know
mattresses were like the poster boy of
the D Toc wave that happened where
Casper and Tu needle and purple got big
raised a bunch of money burned a bunch
of money kind of didn't have a great
exit so these guys came back and now
it's just boring. Co is the name of
their website it's like this is a plain
mattress our friends told us that we
should tell you about all the cool
benefits features that will make this
quote different and quote sellable but
we're not convinced we don't think he'll
fall for that so here's just a really
good mattress that'll last you a while
No Frills and it's only $400 right or
it's like it's cheap yeah 500 bucks and
so that's their new thing and so there's
that's one blueprint in a business is to
do the same thing with less less Frills
actually like you know brand less of a
brand uh pump or or less features that
you needed to to to use Trello is a good
example of this uh all productivity apps
had more and more and more features
Trello was like Hey we're just G to have
less features right it's just the
equivalent of index cards on the
internet that you can move around all
right everyone a quick break to tell you
about HubSpot and this one's really easy
for me to talk about because I'm going
to show you a real life example so I've
got this company called Hampton join
hampton.com it's a community for
Founders doing between 2 million all the
way up to like $250 million a year in
revenue and one of the ways that we've
grown is we've created these cool
surveys and so we have a lot of Founders
who have high net worths and we'll ask
them all types of questions that people
typically are embarrassed to ask but
provide a lot of value so things like
how much the founders pay themselves
each month how much money they're
spending each month what their payroll
looks like if they're optimistic about
the next year and their business all
these questions that people are afraid
to ask but well we ask them anyway and
they tell us in this Anonymous survey
and so what we do is we created a
landing page using hubspot's landing
page tool and it basically has a landing
page that says here's all the questions
we asked give us your email if you want
to access it and then I shared this page
on Twitter and we were able to get
thousands of people who gave us their
email and told us they want this survey
and I could see did they come from
social media I can see did they come
from Twitter from LinkedIn basically
everywhere else that they could possibly
come from I'm able to track all of that
and then I'm able to see over the next
handful of weeks how many of those
people actually signed up and became a
member of Hampton in other words I can
see how much revenue came from this
survey how much revenue came from each
traffic Source things like that but the
best part is I can see how much revenue
came from it and a lot of times it takes
a ton of work to make that happen
HubSpot made that super super easy if
you're interested in doing this you can
check it out hubspot.com the Link's in
the description and I'll also put the
link to the survey that I did so you can
actually see the landing page and how it
worked and everything like that I'm just
going to do that call to action
then and it's free check it out the
description all right now back to MFM
there's actually another takeaway here
though which is how long so you started
an e-commerce company how long until you
hit your first 100,000 in Revenue per
month like three months probably okay uh
you're involved in Shephard uh how long
do you think it took them to hit their
first 100,000 in in Revenue I have no
idea I'm gonna guess six months yeah
quick okay six months so we're talking
months uh Hampton took uh a short amount
of time months as well uh the hustle I
think it took nine months do you know
how long it took followup boss to get to
100 million in revenue or uh sorry
100,000 in monthly uh well you said they
had one customer for 150 bucks like
hanging by a thread for a while so is it
more than a year to get to that first
Milestone four years years four years
four years to get to so I I was reading
this interview with them it took him
four years and they had 11 employees and
they're at 100,000 in in monthly Revenue
they say they they said around ,000 so
it could have been a little bit more but
what's crazy is these software companies
so I don't know what their revenue was
like I said I think it was between 25
and3 if you just Google like follow-up
boss Revenue that's what I saw they sold
for 400 to uh well potentially 500 400
upfront what's crazy is these software
companies we you and I both have this
thing where we want to go fast we need
to learn and have a little bit of this
attitude I got z% of this you are more
of a stick to it kind of guy do you
think I mean if you're under 100,000 in
Revenue four years in are you doing this
still it's hard so like all right so I
have an audience now so do you think do
you think you could have stuck with it
it depends where I was in life if I was
if it was 26 year old Sam 50% chance if
it's where I am now I would say 5%
chance it's it would be really hard it
would be going into those meetings and
be like all right guys we're gonna
review the metrics today uh ear Buffs
everybody we're gonna say the revenue
number and then everybody has to do this
and then I say we're at or 42,000 in
year four and then like all right but
but there's other things to be excited
about but we talked to dares about this
and darash is pretty uh he's pretty
lowkey about it he's like it took
forever in reality darash HubSpot darash
is the founder of HubSpot HubSpot I
think grew like actually a lot faster
but he was like man the first like six
years we only got to like four million
or something I forget exactly what he
said but he like conveyed the idea where
he's like it's a slog at first at that
time things just grew slower
now things grow much faster right the
benchmarks and the expectations are way
different but you have to have faith and
of course we're talking about the one
that worked uh and there's a lot there's
so many more that don't work but like to
have that faith of like this can work
and to stick to it for 10 11 12 years it
if you have the right you know metrics
this pays off this these software
companies are so much cooler than what
we typically start so I did a I remember
many years ago I did a fire side chat
with Michael Burch who was at the time
was you know my mentor he was my boss uh
he's a guy who's built four or five
super successful internet companies that
scaled millions of users he's basically
a billionaire at this point in Silicon
Valley and a bunch of entrepreneurs came
over and they were asking questions one
of the questions they asked was how do
you know when to Pivot or persevere
meaning you hear the stories about
follow-up boss or Pinterest where it's
like there was it was not taking off for
a while and and then you know they stuck
with it and then it did did pictures
take a long time pictures took a long
time um like the graph was you know not
like some explosive social app at the
beginning and um and so they and I I
turned to him because I was like I want
to know this answer too this is
like this is I want to know what is the
guy who's done it in Silicon Valley what
does he what does he say and he goes
this is the hardest question for any
entrepreneur and is deeply personal and
situational he goes for every you know
one story you hear of a Pinterest that
just
keeps going after 12 months even though
there's no signs of life you know
there's a hundred people that did that
and failed and you just never hear they
don't get to talk at the conference
right so he's like it's super hard
because you have this survivorship bias
to
know which story should you listen to
and so he's like he's like this is the
one where there's no real advice you can
get from somebody else the one thing
that we figured out at our company was
like we would set a time box we think we
can hit this Milestone by this date and
setting that time box is really
important because it keeps you honest up
front when you're super optimistic all
right let's say something then we think
that in the first uh like I I set one
for this new company I haven't I haven't
announced it yet on the Pod but I set
one I said I think we can get to 500,000
ARR in the first 60 days so I think we
get to 500k um of Revenue in the first
60 days and I set that now if we don't
hit that doesn't mean I'm gonna like
throw in the towel or shut it down it
meant like but maybe no me you never
know life's on the line for these
companies no but but the reality is you
set that so that you have to have a
conversation about why you didn't hit
your expectations what did what were you
wrong about or what assumption did you
have that was incorrect because it might
be a fatal assumption or might just be
oh I was just I underestimated how long
it takes to do X and that's okay you
could have that conversation the the
thing we did uh when I worked with
Michael was we asked a question what
metric gives us the most Faith so what
metric worries us the most and what
metric gives us the most Faith so let's
say four years in we don't have a
million or we don't have 100,000 in
Revenue that's the one that worries us
the most we have very little Revenue
okay but what gives us the most fi it's
well of the 52 customers we do have they
love it and nobody's churning right then
it's like oh okay what can I hang my hat
on to give myself the excuse to keep
going and so I think that's a useful
question to ask if you if you don't know
whether I should pivot or persevere I
think what metric is giving me the most
faith and what metric is keeping me up
at night and then you can almost kind of
weigh the two against each other um you
know if the thing that's giving you
faith is like yeah that one guy told me
he lik it it's like H that's not a very
strong counter punch to the fact that
the evidence on your revenue and usage
side is pretty low but it feels horrible
when you're in it so I posted a link in
our MDB document okay so it goes to a
tech crunch if you I remember it goes to
Tech crunch article but I remember when
we were running the hustle I looked up
to B there there weren't that many media
companies to look up to and so I really
looked up to Business Insider and the
reason I liked it was Henry BL was
fairly transparent about their traffics
and so Henry blet they wrote an article
it looks like uh maybe six years into
the company and he made a funny joke
he's like we Eed out a net profit of
$2,100 on revenues of 4.8 million uh
it's basically enough to buy a MacBook
Pro and uh and he reveals their traffic
and you see that it looks like this nice
like Arc where it's like or this nice
graph where it's like exponentially
going up but it I remember when I was
running the hustle I was like well their
graph looked amazing like it looked
amazing but then I zoomed in on this
picture and you could see that it's
broken down by month and if you really
focus on it what you could see is
basically February of 09 they hit an
all-time high and then they didn't
surpass that until something like
December of 09 so basically for the
whole year the for 10 months yeah the
whole year which I think they it looks
like they started in ' 07 so for 10
months two years into the company the
monthly traffic which for a site like
Business Insider that's how they would
gauge if they're doing a good job it
basically either went down or didn't go
up and when you do that every single day
every single week for 10 months it feels
miserable and then you zoom out and you
like see like okay well it has gone up
but these graphs are never a smooth
going up and a lot of times sometimes I
imagine for two years it'll be pretty
three years for Years it'll be
and then after a while it starts picking
up if you do a handful of things right
but that requires extreme faith and it's
very very very hard to manage your
emotions every day when it's like that I
totally agree this is a
uh Tony Robin said this thing he goes
the number one choke point of any
business is the psychology of the owner
like every problem you think your
business has if you do the root cause
analysis it goes right back up to the
root to the psychology of the of the
owner right let's say uh oh we're not
growing fast enough why because um you
know we don't have uh our paid
acquisition sucks why why because we the
guy who's running a p acquisition has
been doing it for six months in his life
you don't have somebody experience why
because we're not hiring the right
people why because our owner hasn't made
that a priority and isn't willing to
spend money right or or is afraid to
spend money on on talent and so
everything just goes back to the
psychology of the owner which is both
empowering but also I think scary for
some people the empowering part is it's
in your control the scary part is
it's my fault and it goes back you could
also like go back to like what
inefficiencies or uh like where does the
owner or CEO where do they like suck so
like for example I remember at the
hustle I was always fearful of
overspending and so I was cheap about
and I was actually overly cheap and
when there there was times when Facebook
ads opened up it's like dude we got to
spend more here looking back I should
have spent way more but I didn't because
I was being too cheap and like why am I
cheap well because of all this other
that I experienced in life and so
like it's basically like what do they
say like uh a person with money is they
it's just going to like magnify the
things that the traits that they already
have or or like you always say that with
people when they're drunk like oh your
the true feelings are just going to come
out right it's B the same thing is with
running a company and you got to like
master that inner game and it's really
hard yeah for sure let's do another one
um I want to talk about um let's do you
have this one Peter levels is insane
tell me the Peter levels is insane one
that's a good headline I love this guy
so Peter levels we had in the Pod I
think we've only had him once but he's
got an open invitation if he wants to
come on again so Peter levels we both
love him he uh has like four or five
different businesses that he runs I
think he's by himself doing it
collectively his businesses probably do
two million a year in sales and he's
super transparent about all of it so he
puts his Revenue in his bio on his uh
Twitter he shares everything really
fascinating thoughtful guy did you see
what he did with his stock portfolio so
he basically so click that tweet and
you'll see it but he basically created a
Google sheet and he you can kind of I
don't he doesn't explicitly say it but
you could do the math he says uh here's
how much my stock portfolio made me um
and it was up 32% so you can kind of
like just do basic algebra and figure
out how much he has in his portfolio and
he reveals every holding that he has and
I think that a I'm happy he is doing
this B I would never ever do this though
like it's this is like his transparency
is wild but it's super fascinating to
see what this guy is doing when it comes
to like sharing his numbers uh out in
public it's pretty pretty fascinating I
got to say two things about Peter so uh
first Peter come back on the Pod we miss
you uh you've done a bunch of
interesting stuff this plus your new AI
stuff that we didn't talk about yet so I
want to do that
second we've had a bunch of people on
this podcast some that have big
names some that have you know big uh big
track records or billionaires or built
this hundred billion dollar company or
whatever nobody body and I mean nobody
has a higher approval rating
amongst entrepreneurs on the internet
than Peter levels have you ever met
anybody that is not a fan of Peter
levels I've had billionaire friends like
or Associates in in a in a conversation
and they'll go that guy's doing it right
Everyone likes this guy put this guy's
profile picture up on the on the
screen go go to YouTube and just look at
this guy's profile
picture
this is your personal branding seminar
look at this guy's picture it's him on a
couch in the like International pose of
like guy scheming on the internet just
messing around having fun on the
Internet by himself he's on a couch half
of his body's dangling off he's got his
laptop he's no wearing no shirt he's got
his laptop up on a pillow because you
know the laptop starts to just Scorch
you after a while and he's at this
messed up angle his neck's all messed up
well you know this guy is a oneman band
just having fun and I this is why you're
right CEOs of like you know major
companies are like that guy that guy's
doing it right because everybody is
jealous of being able to be this guy a
guy who's just one man in a laptop
travels around the world builds projects
whatever he wants for fun he builds cool
stuff like an artist that um whatever he
builds tends to have some some juice
behind it because he's a very creative
guy um he's had many failures but who
cares and he's got a bunch of successes
he's very open about them he's not
trying to sell you
anything Peter levels is a hero amongst
makers and nobody I I will contend this
nobody has a higher approval rating on
the internet amongst entrepreneurs than
Peter levels he's great man he's great
and I think on this podcast a lot of
people like oh you're talking about just
big companies too often or whatever and
it's like we always reiterate this is
like we like people who carve their path
and that path could lead to a huge exit
it could lead to something really small
like uh just you could just be a great
artist it doesn't matter if it's a big
money thing or not and Peter level is
the reason why he's so fascinating is he
has carved the hardest path and he
sticks to it he's very value based
really really really cool guy he he did
a tweet that goes he goes only four out
of the 70 projects I've ever done have
made money and grown 95% of everything I
ever did failed by hit rates only 5 per.
so ship more this has 15,000 likes it is
just literally a like a you know like a
vs code like a a screenshot of projects
that made money and grew four he's got
Nomad list remote talk rebase in a
YouTube Network this is before his AI I
think and then here's all of his lit all
of his projects and his stuff like ice
cream chat tual litics gift book te
Taylor telegram chatbot s startup
retreats.com
um places to work fire calculator I
don't even know what any of these are
but each one of these is like you know
uh a great week it's like you know a
great weekend uh that that was had by by
him doing doing these projects you know
that Meme where it's like uh babe wake
up Shawn Pur just tweet it again or like
babe wake up you know like Peter levels
bot domain yeah whenever Peter replies
to one of my tweets it's like one of
those it's like babe wake up Peter just
said he liked what I'm doing that's how
I feel about this guy really cool guy
and I have a theory that people
ultimately what what is lacking in most
people's lives is um that they don't
live life on their own terms and then
the way that that expresses itself is uh
you have a lot of fun when you're living
life on your own terms when you're just
doing your not your thing you're doing
your thing and if you're doing your
thing you're you're having a good time
Peter levels that profile picture of him
on his couch like all crooked just on
his laptop he's doing his thing and I
feel like this is honestly it's a bit of
why people like this podcast we're not
the most prepared or researched or well
spoken whatever but people could tell we
have fun in our lives that we like we
literally just do the that we want
to do and we're having a good time and
it might be that the things we do are
not at all the things you want to do
right Sam's like buying a ranch and like
you know tipping cows and I don't know
what all this you do I don't want
to do all that stuff but I can tell that
you want to do all that stuff and that's
awesome it's great that you want to do
all those things you know build your
like gym and your Farmhouse and whatever
all that good stuff I think that Peter
levels is a great example of somebody
who's just living life on his own terms
and that is one of the most attractive
traits that people have in general and
it's so funny because what most people
do is the exact opposite Peter level has
a bunch of influence but when most
people try to become influencers they uh
you know strip down their personality
and try to um appeal to others and and
people could sniff that out yeah I I I I
just think he's the best and I DM him on
a regular basis he replies to me 10% of
the time so Peter if this makes it to
you come on the Pod man come on come
back on what do you got all right uh
let's do um so another person who is
gone from Zero to Hero
Brian Johnson have you seen the t-shirt
that he wears lately don't die yeah
don't die don't die that's a new that's
a new brand you know what I like about
it it's the same look as the Austin 316
t-shirts
yes I gu should have just done Johnson
316 don't die in fact I might make
Johnson 316 don't die shirts because
that's who he should become um all right
so I was looking the other day because I
saw that Brian Johnson finally started
to sell something and me and you had
made a prediction about six months a
year ago we said you know what I don't
think Brian's doing this for the money I
don't think he's doing this for the fame
although he's gonna make a lot of money
and I'm sure the fame you know the
attention feels good in the moment very
obvious prediction very obvious
prediction but we said dude is this the
greatest pre like pre-launch marketing
stunt ever because what he did was he
basically turned himself into a
character
and a lot of people have done this in
the fitness Niche but he's not a fitness
influencer he he branded himself as a
longevity influencer a live forever a
don't die influencer and he spent couple
million bucks on tests and content and
building his brand he came on pods like
ours and you could look at Google Trends
you could see the interest in Brian
Johnson growing over time actually we
should map out when our podcast was with
him on that Trend because I'm curious
where that was and he has built an
amazing following and he's doing
everything you should do as a as an
influencer not that he wants to be an
influencer but he's doing everything he
should do like I don't know if you've
seen his meetups that he's having lately
these like runs that he's doing yeah
they look awesome they take a people and
they chant like don't die and then they
like run up a hill there were something
like that and then they get at the
bottom and they eat like just there's a
pot of lentils and they're all eating
lentil it's amazing and so he's building
his little cult and it's it's a great
thing so he came out with his first paid
product did you see it it was it it's
the meal service right no no no so he
came out with like a it's kind of like a
meal service it's like basically it's a
a part one of his blueprint diet as a
you know ready to eat sort of like
delivery package I think you pay 330
bucks a month and you get this thing
12,000 people applied wait wait wait but
what is it how's it not you you said I
you implied I was a little wrong with
meal service it is a meal service then
but it's just like powder right yeah
yeah ex it's not like meal delivery it's
not like Blue Apron but it is like you
know the supplements and the drink and
what whatever it's like some version
some skim down version of the um of his
like anti-aging protocol got it it's the
blueprint self-experimentation study and
there's like a level one and there
there's going to be a level two level
three so there's 67 interventions in
this and it looks like there's a couple
of powders there's a bottle of olive oil
and then there's a bunch of pills I like
all those things powders pills powder
pills and oils send me up so he um he
got 5,000 PE he got 12,000 people to
apply 5,000 people paid so so let's do a
little public math here let's break a
rule he just launched this product he
had more demand than he was willing to
let in he let in 5,000 people that's 20
million in ARR that he had on day one of
launching this
produ and 20 million of ARR for a
subscription supplements business
essentially is like a $200 million
business what do you think uh athletic
greens is that Revenue wise they they
rais at 1.2 billion in valuation 100 150
is my maybe 200 wow Max okay not you
know but this is day one day one come
out the gate with 20 million and this is
he let in less than half of the demand
that he had right so he could have been
at 40 million If he if he wanted to
again I don't think he's doing this for
the money but godamn that's a that is an
impressive start to a business and it
shows that I have this phrase now that I
say and my wife doesn't think it's cool
and she's the only one I've tried it on
but I say this I say all content is now
marketing and all marketing is now
content and this is what Brian Johnson
did he was putting out content it
happened to be marketing and that that
marketing is now leading to a lot of
sales um for his new protocol when you
say that to your wife I can just hear
the world's loudest eye roll of like
she's like shut the up Sean that
works on those dorks that
listen to you but take out the
trash
Sean did you warm up the mac and cheese
like I asked you to or not yeah are you
talking about this is awesome it's sort
of like uh have you seen that what's
that movie where they talk about the
biggest short and Ryan goss's character
you know they're like what are you
getting out of this Ryan he goes look
look listen Vinnie you're getting the
ice cream you're getting the nuts you're
getting the chocolate syrup you're get
the Whi cream and when this works out
I'm gonna get the cherry on top that's
my feet I just get a little bit of of
this that's that's that's what uh Brian
Johnson is doing with this business he's
doing everything else I think actually
just cause because he's a dork and he
enjoys this then it just so
happened that he got famous and now he's
like yeah yeah that's pretty cool okay
fine I'll do that too you know and I dig
that and isn't it weird like why do you
think we have so much trust and faith in
this guy it's part of it is because he
already has like the fu money and so we
think like he doesn't give a he's
just doing this just because but the way
that he's turned himself in the
character is actually really interesting
in his case there was a high Bei entry
he spent millions of dollars it seems
doing this he also kind of lived like a
Hermit for two years to like perfect
this but the idea of turning yourself
into a character and then doing it in
front of a lot of people that's actually
a really appealing that's an exciting
route to go for a lot of people where
it's just like you change your identity
and you go all in on this and you could
actually make an make a great living by
doing this it's the same reason I bought
shoes from knees over toes guy right I
probably never bought shoes from any
brand besides Nike in like 20 years and
then I see this guy who's over 40 years
old dunking a basketball I see what he
looked like before he was doing his
thing and how he had knee surg Jes
undeniable proof is a very very powerful
lever this guy literally just does like
a somersault then he gets up and dunks
the basketball and he's like this 45y
old white guy which shoes he came out
with like a pair of shoes um that are
like you know the knees over toes like
thing not great shoes by the way for the
record um definitely don't buy V1 of
anybody's anything um so so you know it
wasn't great but I have a high amount of
faith and trust in this guy because
again all content at marketing so for
two years years he was just putting out
free content didn't sell a thing and so
for two years all he did was put out
very helpful content and showed an
undeniable level of proof that this guy
was in incredible shape that his legs
were super super strong and that you
know where he started to where he was is
a very powerful transformation so
anybody who wants to have that
transformation will trust him and then
when he comes out with a thing and he
says hey this is what I use people will
buy it and it's very very effective by
the way I also bought knees over toes
shoes before he came out with that shoe
cup he was always wearing these other
shoes and I also bought them I also
bought that that white shoe that looks
like it'san that's like $70 or something
$45 couldn't even really get it on I
have like a thick American foot or
something like doesn't fit in this like
European shoe dude I wore the out
of them I love those shoes I like I
remember seeing the picture and like
Googling like what are those shoes
they're not very comfortable they look
cool though what are they like fuer or
something like that like fugazi or it's
like TCH an F I love the fugazi too man
they were they were as hell um can I do
a quick Thrill The Shield by the way
okay go all right so basically at
Hampton we've got access to all this
data and so in order to grow we decide I
love data you know they say data is the
new oil I already mentioned I love oil I
don't know how to I don't know how to
make money off of it yet but somehow oil
is good we've been doing these surveys
where we survey different Industries and
we get benchmarks for different uh
different Industries right now we just
did one on agencies and so we did this
thing where we surveyed 60 agencies they
gave us all their revenue all their
profit and we did like a this cool
survey where we show here's the
benchmarks for profit uh per employee
Revenue per employee you can find it at
if you just go to join hampton.com and
then you go to our blog you'll see the
surveys we did one on wealth so like
people say their net worth how much
money they're spending each month how
much income they're making each month
how much they're working each week we
just did one on agency so if you're an
agency owner check it out but more so
that's that's the shill here's the
thrill part I think Sean that if I if I
decide to do this have you ever heard of
the have you ever I think this could
work have you ever heard of like
benchmarking like I I I didn't know
anything about this industry do you know
anything about benchmarking yeah of
course I didn't know that people would
ever pay for this and so there's the the
most common form of benchmarking is
salary benchmarking so there's a company
called salary.com and then there's like
10 or 20 other ones who have raised
hundreds of millions of dollars whatever
I think in a couple years if I get
enough data I think we could I can spin
this off and create a data company where
I do benchmarking for different industri
and the problem that we'll be solving is
let's say that you're an agency let's
say you're Ecom business and you're
above 50 million in Revenue you want to
know are we spending the right amount
for ads are we spending the right amount
for employees whatever I think we can
build a cool Data Business off of this
so that's the thrill the shill but I
just wanted to call my shot and say
maybe eventually I think we're going to
do this I don't think it's a calling
your shot if you say maybe
eventually calling your shot is I'm
going to do this that's like it's like
the only requirement of calling your
shot is to say I'm going to do this not
call my shot if I happen to be if I so
happen to do this which I probably won't
but it kind of
work it's like if Babe brood just went
like this it's at the point you just
went like kind of
shrugg
like dude also you reminded me of
something I don't mean to to rain on
your your thrill or your shill here but
do you remember have you seen these
leaked I'm sure you've seen this because
we're both internet like uh what's it
called like the people who look for
fossils whatever archaeologist yeah um
when Mark Zuckerberg had his old like
aim messages leaked when he was 19 years
old starting Facebook and he Go's like
these these effing idiots are actually
downloading this here's the transcript
he goes he just DM's a friend just
because you can't wait to BR he goes
yeah so if you ever need anyone if you
ever need any info about anyone at
Harvard just ask I have over 4,000
emails pictures addresses Social
Security numbers his friend goes what
how did you manage that people just
submitted it I don't know why they quote
trust me dumb
this is Sam in his slack about
Hampton he's like yeah every agency just
submitted their profits their revenues
their growth tactics they trust me for
the record I want to say next Zuck dude
dude I want to say I have access to zero
of the documents that people uh submit
for in order to join Hampton I've got
zero access I purposely did this just
like for years I purposely didn't ask
your name of your Ecom business I just
like I don't want to know because I
don't want to accidentally say anything
I have zero access to this not only
because I don't want to say anything and
also because I just literally don't know
how to you know like use computers and
like log in and I don't have a
password that was the equivalent of uh
you know no obla and glass like oh I got
pulled over I don't even speak I don't
even know how to use my computer I I
can't access this stuff trust me all
right let me stop making funny about
that let's let's move on let's do
another one all right so last year I
invested in this company called
consensus and they basically it was like
an AI company for research for like
scientific research so if you wanted to
like figure out like um you know instead
of like reading individual studies this
website would just tell you in aggregate
what many studies would show and they
were only doing okay there it was
basically just two guys and they were
still just trying to figure it out like
it it was like this sounds interesting
but like I don't even know if this is
going to work let's see well something
happened a few weeks ago that I think is
going to change their business but I
think it there's an inflection so
basically like when the iPhone came out
the App Store happened and we heard
stories about Pandora so Pandora was a
company before they were the music
service the App Store came out and
they're like oh let's just use our
service and pivot and build an app they
were one of the first apps that's what
made Pandora popular when covid happened
there's companies like betterhelp which
is like uh uh therapy online or there's
like tele medicine because the laws
during covid changed where a doctor can
prescribe meds cross state lines there's
been a lot a bunch of these right now
one just happened so I think January
14th so I think it was 10 or January
10th open AI created an App Store
they've kind of did done this where
they've like made their own like you can
make your own GPT and all this other
stuff but they' they created an App
Store I don't even think they said what
the pricing was so with the iPhone app
store
I think the developer gets what 70% of
the revenue Apple gets 30% open AI
hasn't even said what that what it's
going to be so they're still really
early and so this company that I
invested in they're like oh well like
our thing is going okay but like what if
we just like went all in on this like
plugin for open AI store and so their
version is basically like you just type
in you ask it questions medical
questions and it just gives you a
slightly better answer than open AI but
it's a lot better or at least enough
that you want to pay for and there's not
that traffic right now or not that many
new apps in the open AI open AI App
Store but this is one of those
inflection moments so here's a two more
examples so you remember honey that
company that was like uh uh what do they
do did coupon codes for a website and
then grammarly did the same thing they
both did that with the Chrome Store you
have a bunch of friends because you kind
of ran in that world where people did
this with with the Facebook uh platform
so Zinga I don't know how much money
they eventually made but it was at one
point a multi-billion dollar company I
think right now now we're going to see
like a Facebook store you're going to
see like all these Mafia Wars all these
like weird games I think you had a buddy
what was the guy's name Dan who went to
Camp FM who started like OMG pop or
something like that what was that called
Draw Something was the game that
everybody played and it I I think he had
a multi hundred million doll exit I
think this is right now about to happen
with the open AI like plug-in store it's
really fascinating what's happening I
thought this was interesting you asked
the guy or somebody asked the the the
founder he said I think it's going to be
something between like more than the
Chrome extension Market but less than
the App Store you know shortterm it's
awesome for marketing and functionality
for users um and open AI is footing the
bill on a lot of the compute costs um in
the med medium term we have 2X the usage
of the next biggest GPT and I think
canva is the next so this is the number
one GPT yeah yeah it's taking off and
these guys they're smart guys but it was
still when they were starting their
company when we invested it was like uh
I don't know hopefully we'll figure it
out and there was a time where I was
like you guys better figure this out
soon like I don't know if this is going
to work out and then this inflection
happened this change happened dude this
product is awesome I just went to their
site I didn't do the chat gbt thing but
just their app it's really cool so you
go there you ask any questions so I just
did are microplastics dangerous for
humans and then it has all these papers
but then you hit synthesize which I
think is the credits that you have to
buy if you but you start with 23 credits
and it says summary we looked at 10
papers the study suggest microplastics
are dangerous for humans and they carry
toxic chemicals um contaminating
ecosystems and are linked to various
health issues including cancers and
immune system disruptions and then it
says we looked at the 14 papers yes was
43% of the time possibly 57% of the time
no 0% of the time and that was the like
that was the thing and then you could
see below each specific paper and it's
like tagged like oh this is a rigorous
Journal This is highly cited um and you
can kind of get AI to Summarize each of
those papers this is this is a sick like
this is a sick product it's cool and it
but by the way just like all great stuff
it did not start that way I'm mad you
didn't tell me about this this is I why
did I invest in this this is great it
wasn't obvious by the way it's still not
obvious this company just like any any
startup it could still totally fail and
not work no but it's a very interesting
BET right like to do a verticalized
Google specifically for scientific
papers and AI being the the the why now
of what you could do differently than
you could do before this makes a lot of
sense and it was uh I'll give the shout
out it's consensus. apppp that's their
website but the point being a consensus
is great I think it's actually going to
work out and these guys uh they they
kind of put their head down for like 24
months and like are really starting to
figure out there's going to be a lot of
stuff just like them on the chat gbt
store because I think when we invested
in them I don't remember exactly I'm
almost positive the word AI didn't come
up one time like it wasn't like it was
like we have this like I we know what
the outcome that we want to it what we
want it to be but we're not entirely
sure how we're going to come to that and
then they started figuring out AI got
more popular and then this chat gbt
store opened up and they're like like
boom we found the path and I think that
path is opened right now now it's more
competitive than than the App Store and
it's more competitive than Chrome
because there's more people who are
doing this stuff open AI is already huge
but that inflection is happening right
now this is one of those things that's
happening in real time and I wanted to
call out because I think open AI even
said we don't even know how what payment
terms we're going to give these people
like we're they're still all figuring it
out but this is happening this second
right now there's an opportunity here
for a lot of different companies they're
like around like you know some celebrity
relationship they like oh we don't we
don't know we don't want to put a label
on it yet we're just we're just
exploring each other and figuring out
you know who we are together and
individually yeah it's definitely trying
to figure it out have you seen um
perplexity have you used perplexity I
don't like it I don't know why people
are going nuts for it it's pretty cool
it's just like open AI but for some
reason it's like has a science bent
that's one of these companies I I don't
know I don't know much about it I this
is a uninformed opinion but I feel like
every VC who missed like you can't get
into open AI or if you could get in now
it's at100 billion doll valuation
there's not much money to be made as an
investor there and so all the capital
you know realized all the investors
realized holy this is the big thing
and they're like What's the next best
competitor and they're like all right uh
stable diffusion and perplexity and the
next thing and the next thing and they
get these super inflated valuations and
um I don't know I'm not not really a
believer in that I I think those get way
ahead of the skis and I just seen that
story many times this in crypto this
happened in uh you know when mobile when
mobile was happening and you would get
you know for every Instagram you would
then get the 10 superf funded other apps
that didn't make any sense and um yeah I
would take I would take the under or I
would short that uh that uh after the
Pod go to your email and type in
consensus I'm almost positive that I
heard about this company and you were
cced on the email just I just want to
put that out there I I it was a 20 it
was two years ago I'm almost positive
the Pod take some lighter fluid pour it
over your body light them
back and hope no one finds what finds
out what happens we're gonna burn it
down and hide it do a rant about
something so I've had a realization that
my world like a lot of the content I'm
consuming was algorithmic all right
that's pretty obvious you every what
does that mean just Twitter Tik Tok
whatever yeah everything I was using
you'd go to um you go to Twitter it's an
algorithm telling you here's the content
you need to see you go to Tik Tok
algorith Facebook Instagram yes all of
that even uh email email is not really
algorithmic exactly but it's uh you go
there and it's here's what other people
want you to to look at here's my problem
hey here's my problem readed me right
and then same thing same thing with you
know all news go to a News website hey
here's everybody's problems on the other
side of the world here you know pay
attention to
this I'm calling it The intentional
internet which is I started really being
intentional about oh no no no no if I'm
going on the internet right now what is
it that I want to see what is it I'm
curious about what is it that I want to
learn about and then I go in and I'm
stiff arming algorithms left and right
uh you know I'm Marshon Lynch on that
one run where he just sheds eight
Defenders goes all the way and just
rumbles to the end zone that's me on the
internet now and I think more people
should be doing this join me on the
intentional internet where you get on
and you don't just you're not just uh
you know little puppy just eating the
puppy child that the algorithms give you
go on with some intent and say what is
it that I'm looking for I want maybe
it's I want certain type of
entertainment maybe it's I want a
certain type of information or I want to
be inspired okay so then go look for the
things that will give you that follow
that way you follow 13,000 people
on on Twitter the trick is you don't go
to Twitter right what do you do well
Twitter's not a great place for this
right because if you go to Twitter
you're GNA get your first things you're
going to start up is the feed and you're
gonna start scrolling what are you g to
start reading books that's very unlike
you so I make a little list I say you
know what curious how this started or I
want to learn more about this and then
I'll go to YouTube or Google or wherever
looking for that but just that adding
that little paper step in between me and
the internet has been very very useful
and I learned a bunch of interesting
things the last three days I got more
out of the internet so I'm just putting
that out there for anybody who what's
been on your list I'll give you an
example um I was doing research for one
thing and I saw this name do you know
this guy Eric
vanven yes he's amazing I have got him
oh wait are you talking about Ricky
vanine or Eric uh oh maybe he's Ricky
Ricky Van Ricky Facebook guy Facebook
dude Dy super
dreamy this guy's Drey as I've
talked to him a bunch via email a
handful times the internet PE budge or
something no man this gu's great so this
guy created College Humor yeah and then
he created um a couple other things so
what did he create create college humor
and then he he created a few other
things like cracked or whatever then he
bundled it up sold it to IAC it was
running media at IAC and then he you're
forgetting the thing they started which
one so at College Humor this was like
pre- YouTube days they create this was
like e-bombs World days they created a
better way to host videos yeah and
that's what Vimeo is which they sold the
IAC IAC spun off and became a billion
dollar plus publicly traded company so
creates Vimeo creates College Humor goes
to IAC IAC is a super interesting
company with like a very cool pedigree
of people that come out of it like
Tinder came out of I um you know there's
there's a bunch of really interesting
things about I they they're sort of like
the co they're the Proctor and Gamble of
the internet they're a conglomerate of
internet sites mostly media and then
match.com I think came out of there now
he's head of like create head of like
video or head of creative content at
Facebook and I was like oh this guy's
interesting I kind of just noted it uh
because I think I was thinking about
college humor and um so I just who who's
behind that what are they doing now and
I think this this what are they doing
now has been one of my threads so I'll
I'll think of something that was cool
and I'll be like where did they go I
haven't heard about their new album what
what are they working on and I'll go
look at that and that's just a very it's
a very useful um way to go look at
things so by the way Ricky Ricky ended
up marrying and I don't think they're
together anymore but like if you just
you could just Google like tabloids or
whatever he married Allison Williams you
know the famous like actress whose
father is Brian Williams the famous
newscaster and if you Google his name
the guy's just like hanging out with
like all these celebrities and stuff and
he's like seems so cool like this guy's
dreamy as strategy Facebook so
anyways what what what's my point so I
I'm I'm I have a list of cool companies
or cool things that were built you know
10 years ago and I'm wondering what are
those people doing now College Humor was
one of them so I go look at this guy and
then I'm like I'm researching Vimeo and
I'm looking at him and then I'm like he
gave this talk in um 2008 at this media
conference and then he comes back again
eight years later I don't know if you've
ever seen this talk but it's a it's a I
mean it gets no views on the internet
but for nerds like us who create media
and content on the Internet it's very
interesting to see what somebody thought
in 2008 which is like the iPhone has
come out but it hasn't changed the world
yet and like literally the presentation
he's like yeah kids on their
blackberries are not going to be doing
XYZ and back then um you know when he
created College Humor it became the
number
one um comedy entertainment site on the
internet way bigger than Cartoon Network
and all these other like incumbents okay
that's interesting then he comes back
eight years later and he's like here's
what I got right and here's what I got
wrong and one of the things he was
talking about on it he's like he's like
at some point people on the internet
will stop leaving the internet like they
won't they they'll stop using the
internet as a springboard to go onto
Netflix or onto get get cast into a TV
show or whatever like they'll realize
that their YouTube channel is worth more
than than those shows and they won't
want to leave um to to go do those they
W view this as just a stepping stone and
that's happened he basically had like
four or five predictions about where
where the world was going he put up the
all the sites like uh Viral Nova and
Upworthy and whatnot he's like right now
these are the hottest sites in the world
their traffic is crushing ours and
they're they're getting more traffic
than anybody more traffic than God it's
like I think all of this is going to
zero I think this is highly commoditized
and it's not going to work for these
reasons it was absolutely correct and so
it was very interesting to learn from
this guy who's kind of a master at what
he does and I've done this before with
like um when I looked up all the
infomercial Kings so the guys who
created like you know proactive that
acne uh you know medicine like how did
that story happen right but if I just
log on the internet and I just take the
the the last thing that somebody tweeted
or the latest Tik Tok somebody uploaded
you know I'm playing defense I'm playing
their game not mine right so I'm just
trying to have a little bit more
intention when I when I when I use the
Internet it's you know I'm not the type
who's just going to go uh like total
digital detox and just not use the
internet but when I do use it I'm trying
to use it in a bit of a healthier way so
Ricky did he he predicted that the viral
novas of the world are he predicted it
was going to go to zero and they did
yeah did I ever tell you the story about
my partner Joe in Hampton um and a bunch
of other stuff did I tell you a story
about little things you've mentioned it
before that he got like really the most
trafficked Facebook referral right and
then he had an offer to sell and he
didn't take it or something is that the
story so Joe Joe's an amazing
entrepreneur so he started his first
company it was an adte company he sold
it for hundreds of millions of dollars
when he was like 25 so he just had this
like huge success at a young age then
his next business he started was called
the I forget exactly what it was called
but a pet flow it was a pet food company
and they started it before chewy except
he was a little conservative and he was
like we have to spend money profitably
on ads and that's hard to do and so
we're going to go a little bit slower
chewy comes in and goes n f that we're
gonna lose money for the first six or 12
months at a customer and we're going to
do such a good job that they're going to
come back and Joe was like that's a dumb
strategy turns out it was right but in
order to make uh pet flow grow he
created a Blog where they just wrote
content on pets and within a very very
very very short amount of time they
started getting 10 20 30 million people
a month coming to this blog on pets and
he's like ah screw that let's just do
this blog and So within four years they
were the most shared website on Facebook
bigger than Viral Nova bigger than
BuzzFeed bigger than huffpo all these
Publishers that were huge in the 2014 15
era and it started getting something
like 250 million uniques a month to
their website and they were scaled up I
think to 90 million in Revenue in four
years it was a huge company I went to I
cold emailed him I went to his office he
had these Studios and they're like
Facebook Liv is the next big thing we
just built out this $250,000 studio in
the in the Manhattan office and it's
going to be the greatest thing ever we
have 150 employees it's gonna be the
biggest thing ever the problem of course
that we all know was Zuck does what Zuck
wants and they built this entire company
little things.com on the back of
Facebook and they got a an Loi to sell
the business and they were literally
three weeks from selling they were going
to sell for hundreds of millions of
dollars Facebook puts out this annual
report they go we're actually changing
we're pivoting from this thing to this
thing and three weeks away or something
like that from this deal closing for
hundreds of millions of dollars the
company uh backed out and within six
months the business basically laid off
everyone and had uh shut down all in a
matter of like six or seven months of
like we're on top of the world making
100 million a year to now we are not and
it's a crazy crazy story if you Google
like his name Joe spyer little things
you'll see the story uh I think uh Inc
just did some big story on it but it's
pretty wild ah the lessons we learn
unfortunately that's you know that's
like uh it's it's cool to be like yeah
you learned so much from failure but
it's like God sometimes it's so painful
yeah he was basically win he posted this
publicly he was like I was set to make
$50 million and three weeks away from it
closing it went away and I he like has
Crazy by what's he like to work with
because you picked him as your partner
for Hampton uh why'd you pick him he's
the best man he's the best he's the best
he's a harmonious partner he's even Kio
he's very easy not like the partnership
Dynamics because you've told me about
those what is he what's his Edge what's
he great at what's what is he like what
is he amazing at you ever hang out with
Israeli guys and like Israeli guys have
a culture of like they're quite
competent because they served in the
military and they're like really good at
stuff oftentimes they're good at
spotting opportunities because that's
also part of the culture of like just
like negotiating well and like finding
interesting deals he is so good at
spotting opportunities and he's
Technical and he's so fast I've never
met someone who's like significantly
faster than I am at making stuff and
going all in and like he'll just find an
opportunity he'll build a website for it
and he's like Yep this is what I'm doing
now and he pounces so fast I've never
met someone who moves faster one thing
that we did that was so great did you
ever have this with Ben or any of your
partners where you do like a um you're
like look before we like hop in bed and
before we get married here let's just
sit down and map out what do you want
your life to be like what do you want in
five years and 10 years what do you want
on a day-to-day basis and you like write
out like how you want to live what
you're willing to uh what you're willing
to give up what you're not willing to
give up have you ever done that not
exactly but you know you told me you did
that I think there's a version of that
that I do but I'm not I think everything
changes uh so you know it sounded really
great in theory and I think it's a
useful exercise just to clarify your own
thoughts but I
don't I think people themselves are
quite incongruent in
general well yeah you change you uh you
change but also you don't know what you
want and also you say one thing because
it sounds good or you think you want it
but then something comes you know
something comes up and you're you know
it's your stated preference versus your
revealed preference I think it's very
hard to get to people's revealed
preferences their true preferences or
their true um their true you know
desires or whatever
and so I think it's a good exercise to
do but I don't put as much weight in it
as you did I
think well I think that I think that a
it starts a really good conversation so
like look let's be transparent just like
you should with like your wife or
girlfriend you're like let's talk about
like what type of life that we
potentially want and let's be very open
about that so I think that that like
creating that like let just be very
clear about and we we'll acknowledge
that it will change so I think it
creates a great version of that but
Joe's also 42 I think he's older than
than me and so I would think that at
that age he has a little bit of
solidified the values that he stands for
and so it was helpful I think if I did
that exercise when I was 24 it would not
have been good in fact I did do that
exercise when I was 24 and it sucked I
said I wanted you want to know what I
said I wanted when I was 24 I said I
want 10,000 employees I go wouldn't it
be awesome if we had 10,000 employees
and then I hired three people and and
I'm like went out the window I'm like
yeah that's that's know for me dog like
that a going to work but so I think if
you're a little bit older and you have
some experience you might know a little
bit more you want but when I was younger
no that wouldn't have worked my uh
thinking on this is the buffet thing of
you want some a partner with energy
integrity and intelligence I think
that's the like core thing you I look
for at least which is basically and in
order energy is the easiest to spot and
it's the easiest one to try to write off
if somebody doesn't have it um meaning
seems like a seems like a nice to have
it's actually not a nice to have for me
it's a must have for me um and so energy
is the first one that shows up and it's
the easiest one that I've tried to talk
myself out of with certain people and
that's been a mistake every single time
I've done it who have you worked with
that's high energy and like almost
exhausts you because you're like I can't
keep up su's like that uh he's super
high energy but not in an exhausting way
in a like I get energy from that so it's
all good I don't mean exhausting like
they wear you out but you're like oh my
god dude like you're you're almost hard
to keep up you move so fast that's
inspiring yeah everybody
yeah it's but it's in a good way um like
pace and that they bring their own
energy to the table I'm not bringing it
out of them um Ben is a fun so Ben Levy
who's my current business partner on the
surface when you meet him he's a more
quiet guy he's more reserved he's not
like he doesn't come across like this
huge booming personality but Ben's got
that energy where he just it comes out
for him like through text message or
through like you know he he'll just wake
up and do something or he can't sleep at
night because he's thinking about
something so energy reveals energy is
not just being a wacky flaing arms guy
it's do you have the are you driven
yourself do you take action quickly do
you think about things all the time or
are you am I trying to force you to to
am I dragging your brain into the
conversation and do you get excited
about things are you when an opportunity
arises does your do you shift gears up
so energy is the first one then it's um
intelligence or competence which is like
what are they great at oh this person's
great at selling this person is great at
building this person's great at um just
pushing the ball forward every day uh
whatever it is and then the last one
which is integrity is the hardest one to
get a feel for which is how's this
person going to treat me when they have
the opportunity to be selfish will they
be selfish when they have the
opportunity to be selfish and it's very
very hard to know that you can kind of
only talk to people they've worked with
before or ask them questions and try to
see if they're they're pretty honest
about that um and then I just work with
them on something first before we commit
so it's like we have that conversation
sure but let's like you know I would
always trade an experience for a belief
and if I can have an experience working
with you on something for three weeks
that's going to be way better than me
trying to put take a leap of faith on a
bunch of things you said or you wrote
down in a Google doc did you just make
up that word or that phrase Tony Robin
special maybe quote Oh I was gonna say
that's that's yours now do you uh what
how late into the evening are you
working on business stuff versus family
time or Fitness or whatever else there
is um I basically I work out in the
middle of the day I work about 2 2 p.m.
uh so it's basically like I've done I've
done enough where I could stop working I
wake up and I work I wake up I do my
morning routine then I work and then I
take a break to work out and then I'll
either just if I've done enough that day
I'll just play with my kids I'll start
playing with them and just hang out if I
if I have it I'll do another hour or two
of work and then I do family time till
about till they go to bed so they're you
know usually fully asleep 8:30 or 9 and
then I chill out slash work one of the
two they're both kind of the same to me
so some sometimes it's just like
watching a show sometimes it's working
or reading something and I'll do that
till 11 or 12 when I go to go to sleep
but between that 11 or between kid kids
going to sleep and you going to bed are
you on the phone talking to people ever
no no no that's me time that's uh me on
the internet uh I'm not talking to
people no I uh I've got a bunch of
friends who are like that and they even
my wife she'll try to talk and I will be
like I'm doing no talking that's my
friend I'm doing no talking right
now it's a it's a nice way of saying
like I don't want to talk to you I'm
doing no talking that's it this thing
there's like this like unspoken rule at
my house where like at 8 or 9 when she
wants to like ask me like hey what dates
do you want to go uh to this place and I
just Mumble I
go that means like dude I just shopped
at Ikea all day I'm overwhelmed I can't
look at anything I'm I can't think don't
ask me a date I'm not thinking about
anything you know we've been you know
what we've been doing lately is
like Legos have you ever done Legos I've
never done Legos I I have a whole
separate pod topic about adult Legos
because I think it's a thing and you're
one of those so we should talk we should
actually do a full segment on it I'm so
into it I'm so into it that's all I'll
say I am so I just got into it in
November I'm a Lego guy now I love it
okay we're gonna talk about that next
time I gotta jump uh this has been good
this is the pod that's the pod that's
the
[Music]
pod